hello and welcome to the ninth
fundamental investing with use of
programming tutorial where we left off I
was showing you guys how to basically
get the all of the tickers of companies
located within the Russell 3000 compiled
them into an array and then kind of left
it with the that I was going to run it
through our Yahoo Finance stats and find
eligible companies just so happens that
I ran it through that entire the entire
Russell 3000 against the Yahoo stats
using our requirements of let me scroll
down your price to book well I changed
these numbers but originally we want our
price to book ratio of less than 1 P eg
price to equity 2 or I'm sorry price to
earnings of growth for the last or for
estimated 5 years we wanted that to be I
believe less than 1 I think I edited
this to be - to allow - we originally
were requiring debt-to-equity to be
under 1 this was the most outrageous one
most of these companies had just
enormous debt to equities there were
some that sorry about that Skype message
there's some that were like 200 plus
it's insane and then we also wanted the
p12 trailing we wanted that to be less
than 13 I think is what our value was
before I raised it up to 15 and then if
it met you know at least these
requirements here it spits them out we
really only did this our I only did this
just so we could have something to like
look at all right because there's
literally no company in the Russell 3000
that met the standard requirements so
and that shouldn't be too big of a
surprise given you know that that was
those are these are value investing
requirements that we've chosen and the
idea of value investing is to buy under
priced undervalued companies and right
now let me just drag it over this is our
current S&P 500 for the last one year so
as you can see I mean we are clearly at
a very high point
in our stock market just gonna be kind
of hard to find companies that are like
just very depressed to the point of
being undervalued so anyway and if
anything there there's a bit of a risk
here just simply seeing that there's
literally no undervalued company that's
crazy I really thought that we would
find something anyway so with these
requirements here with the price to book
under to be a g5 under to no debt to
equity requirement was made we're just
gonna kind of go by Iran that sits still
printed out for us to look at but it's
not gonna make a requirement and then
the trailing price-to-earnings we
require that to be under 15 right that's
probably the fairest measure really at
least by value investing standards that
you're really looking for something that
is in the bottom 10% of compared to its
competitors so anyway I ran this through
the Yahoo dataset and we actually got
quite a few and at the end I've had it
print out every ticker that matched it
so these were all of the tickers that
matched it so we can definitely whittle
this down a little bit
I did save that ticker so the next time
I like if you do want to whittle it down
you know so the first time you might run
it with pretty wide allowances and then
you can have it spit out you know this
ticker here that I spit out and the way
that you do that is if it meets all of
your requirements to this point I just
made an empty array here at the top well
at least in the other scripts not in
this script but if it met all the
requirements then what it did was append
the stock to of interest but now I'm
gonna actually comment this out because
we don't want to be doing that again so
like if I whittled this down a game like
we could say you know even better right
as an array make it an empty array and
then if we say okay now we're going to
look for companies that are priced a
book one and then come down here and
then we would add you know it's a of
interest even better
and one and then down here you know so
you actually get the array even better
so here's what we'll do is we'll leave
we'll do that and let's say we're gonna
require a price to book let's see I'm
trying to think which one we would want
to move next if it's price to book PG I
think we'll be fine because we that's a
forward PG and I don't really want to
raise this p12 so I think price the
books the best thing to lower so let's
see if we can if everything in this of
interest what we'll do now is we'll run
it in so instead of for each stock and
the roast of three thousand let's say
each stocking that of interest what are
we working with and before I go well I
guess it's not a big deal we could
probably just run that now but I'll just
drink drag this over so we could run
that but anyway over here we can see
here the you know Excel met the
requirements this is not the first time
we've seen Excel on our list it's got a
decent price - but PG you know for
expected is very low the trailing p/e G
however or I'm sorry the PG five is low
and it's that means pretty good
requirements the trailing p/e is also
very low with ten point five six that's
pretty good
but debt-to-equity basically how much
debt do they have compared to their
equity and this has 14x their debt so
not sure that's good but again it's you
know by these other stats you know Excel
is pretty good so I mean it would
warrant probably a second look into
Excel there then we've got this company
now there's 66 I'm trying to find one
that has like a massive one some of
these yeah this guy this company here WD
149 times and they're also over there
the one price a book here's one that
it's perfectly one pretty decent stats
so that's equity I don't see let's see
like the company here like I say say
they have a not available if you recall
the last time I spoke about not
available you it usually means that it's
a negative value and in this case it
also means it's a negative value so how
can we have a scenario where
equity is a negative number I think a
good basically it means that they have
they owe more debt than the value of the
things that they pulled the debt on most
likely or they owe more debt than they
actually have of equity so how could
this happen I think a good example of an
occurrence of this is what I see often
times when I brought a go buy like a
used motorcycle or a used car they'd
have you know it'd be a nice nice
motorcycle a nice car or we'll just go
with the car for now
and you know I'd message the buyer and
be like you know I really like your car
but the price is pretty high you know
can we can we work on that price you
know the price probably you know 10%
over market value right and you talk to
them and and pretty quickly what would
come out is well I owe this much I owe
this money on the car loan and that's
why I'm charging as much money so they
owe more money on the debt right on the
loan for their vehicle then their
vehicle is even worth it's depreciated
since the loan and the sense the value
of the vehicle so so they actually owe
more money than they even have in equity
so it's a very bad situation to have so
I would probably I would really rule out
any company that has a negative debt to
X just that's very scary so anyway yeah
that's that and so put a few these
actually have negative numbers but
anyways what I'm gonna do now is run
through requiring or price-to-book less
than one
now I've explained everything added at
least showed you how you can begin
building these kind of various arrays so
you can think of it almost as like a
watch list right so you you know you can
pull the Russell 3000 let's say you you
could probably you probably pull the
Russell 3000 you know maybe every few
months or something it's probably rarely
that you need to update this list and
then of the of interest stocks you could
probably run this every three months and
maybe change a few stocks in and out of
this I would especially probably you
know if there's ever like a severe
market downturn or the markets go up
significantly or something you know
that's when you're gonna get most of
these companies changing in and out of
this this array
and then you know so like this is your
kind of watchlist and this is an even
deeper watchlist and then obviously you
know of our true requirements of
companies that we'd be like let's buy
today here right there was none today so
you know we're really only gonna have
watch lists probably for this entire
series but at least I'm showing you guys
how you would go about it
to the point of actual purge or at least
you know deciding to read up on the
company so anyway what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to run through the of interest
stocks figure out who has all the stocks
have less than a 1 ratio and really I
would say if de not equals let's see I
think the only thing I would change is
oh we're I'm not gonna worry about that
now actually but probably you would say
like if de not equals not available then
give us that as well make that a
requirement but yeah a lot of these
companies just have like huge debt to
equity ratios so anyway that's that I'm
going to run it through and then I'll
continue on in the next video as always
thanks for watching thank you Bruce for
your subscriptions and until next time